uh let's keep it with basketball
protesters in new york city holding a
freedom rally in support of nba
superstar kyrie irving of brooklyn and
against the vaccine mandate that benched
him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
while some protesters charged brooklyn's
barclays center ahead of the home opener
tried to get in mostly including our
next guest peacefully protested the
state's vaccine mandate john matlin
organizer of the new york freedom rally
joins us now john why go to bat for
kyrie irvin
uh so kyrie is um just somebody on a big
scale that's facing what we like
healthcare workers teachers and city
workers are now facing um he's just on a
very big scale and he lost his job in a
very very big public eye so did you just
supporting him
yeah yeah but the difference between me
is i'm an unsung hero in healthcare and
kyrie is a hero around the world through
sports and entertainment so this is just
a very big picture
of what happened to to the everyday
average person in a superstar format so
um this is kind of a springboard to get
the message out there in general that
these mandates are unjust and are
affecting everybody because some people
have been sleeping on it right uh now i
hear you i mean we see it from
massachusetts the firefighters to uh to
the cops and we see it in seattle we see
it in washington state we're going to
see the new york 36 000 could lose their
jobs two weeks before christmas we're
understanding it so john you're a uh
you're a
ct scan technologist and you were told
after 15 years hit the road you're fired
over in staten island how hard was it to
get this group together what made up
this protest
okay so new york freedom rally is has
already been established
the only difference between what we
usually do which has drawn up to 2 000
people in the streets and it's not it's
not largely reported on tv but it's
happening every weekend on weekdays
this time we actually teamed up with
black lives matter greater new york
and hawk newsome brought some people
down reverend mccall brought some people
down
this is all about unifying on one common
goal
i know that blm is very upset about
what's going on and how it's affecting
their community
they've pledged to have five days of
action uh so things are just are just
seems to be heating up as everybody's
unifying for the same cause why storm
the gates
well the gates so what happened i i kind
of saw that all go down um and then the
police kind of just let everyone go and
stand in the uh and right where you walk
in right as what happened in the front i
wasn't close to it but uh some of the
camera crew that i had with me were able
to get some images
um i i feel like uh the main goal for
that is is kind of creating a
disturbance that uh it wouldn't have
even really been spoken much about on
the media had it not occurred i think
that's the thought behind it but again
there's a lot of different things in
play now there's uh there's so many
great people who feel the same way about
the vaccine on all different education
all different backgrounds they just are
not being listened to uh john thanks for
standing up i appreciate what you're
doing
yeah and uh bill pepitone for mayor
because he's going to turn all of this
uh around for us and he's going to save
the city city workers are meeting today
um at 9 metro tech and they were
marching over the brooklyn bridge so i
hope you guys are there all right uh
we'll have the cameras uh for sure i'm
steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm
ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis